that piece originated from talking with
Frank for editor of the New Republic and
we were talking and the Huckabee's
ascendance in the in the polls was
fueled a lot by his image in the
National Press as a genial fun-loving
guitar-playing governor you know he was
famous for you know running a marathon
and losing all this weight and most most
people if you ask them on the street the
general sense would be that this is a
you know pretty easygoing guy which
contrasted with his reputation and
legacy as governor in the 1990s and
Arkansas you know the Arkansas press
corps had long experience feuding with
him and and really seeing the other side
of his temper and so the piece just
originated from you know seeing his
portrait as a national figure compared
with his his reputation as a local
politician and just sort of seen the
disparity there and trying to fill fill
in the gaps a little bit between his his
national image and his local one it was
a pretty straightforward process I mean
a lot of it was talking to reporters who
covered him and it's not it's the other
dynamic of the story that's interesting
is that when you have reporters who know
someone so well and they've covered him
for years as a local candidate and a
local official that they oftentimes know
him on a much different level than the
national press corps who who sort of
parachutes in once he's become a viable
contender and so you know so these guys
down in Arkansas were just scratching
their heads because you know the guy
that they are reading about on the cover
of the New York Times Magazine or cover
of Newsweek was not the governor that
they knew from Arkansas so I think a lot
of it was that they were just happy to
talk about the governor that they knew
and these these private letters were
were a pretty humorous example of his
temper the letters were written to a
newspaper editor named max Brantley and
they were they were distinguished for
their their attention to detail and
Huckabee really wanted Brantley to know
that he didn't leave you know any any
stone unturned in his animosity for him
and and you just the funny thing is you
realize that you would one would think
that a governor a state governor would
be busy enough that he really wouldn't
sweat the small stuff in the minutia
that are that sometimes happens in in
the presses coverage of him but he he
just had a whole litany of grudges
against Brantley that he expounded on in
these letters you know they hounded them
and that the piece was closing his
spokeswoman issued a statement that that
was unrepentant and Huckabee it was
funny because you know was one of the
few times as a national candidate he
flashed some of his temper from from his
Arkansas days and they basically their
point was that these were just some
disgruntled Arkansas reporters who were
trying to interject themselves into the
process